The idea of cultural appropriation is
absolute nonsense.
That's that.
No,
there's no difference between cultural
appropriation and learning from one
another.
It does the same thing.
Now,
that doesn't mean I can't.
That doesn't mean that there's no theft
between people.
There is no,
and it doesn't mean that just because
you encounter someone else's ideas,
you have an immediate right to those
ideas as if they were your own,
but the idea that manifesting in your
own behavior,
some element of another culture,
the idea that that's somehow immoral is
insane.
It's actually one of the bases of peace.
You know,
one of the things that the various
groups of human beings that exist have
to offer each other is the tremendous
value of their culture.
You know,
it's been really interesting to me,
for example,
to watch the response of,
of ball of everyone,
but for this argument to you,
for young Caucasian males to hip hop,
you know,
there's an aggressiveness about hip hop
that's really attractive to young
Caucasian males and there's something
observed about,
about the,
the spectacle of the young Caucasian
males taking on the persona of inner
city black gang members.
You know,
but,
but I'm sympathetic to it because there
is an aggressiveness to that,
to that art form that's a necessary
corrective to the insistence that the
highest moral virtue for a modern man is
harmlessness,
which is observed.
Women don't even like harmless man.
They hate them.
Okay.
Flog them apart.
What,
what
are dangerous men who are civilized and
they want to help civilize them
beauty and the beast.
So,
you know,
I'll tell you a funny story and only
engineers could have come up with this
because they are the only ones that have
the unparalleled blindness to social
convention that would allow them to
discover it.
So the Google engineers,
I like engineered by the way because
they're very straightforward.
The Google engineers wrote a book awhile
back called a billion wicked thoughts,
which was a study of Internet searches,
billions of them literally,
and they were looking a lot of
pornography use.
And while there's lots of known about
male pornography use,
partly and it's easy to understand.
I mean males are pretty visually
oriented in what attracts them to
pornography is fairly straightforward.
You can tell that if you look at
graffiti and a men's washroom,
you know it's like two circles in the
triangle and the men are absolutely
transfixed.
Bye.
The story is more complex.
They use pornography too,
but it tends to be literary because
women tend to like words more.
They like visual stimuli and so the
Google guys tried to track down the
archetypal structure of how they didn't
use those words a female pornography
use.
And so some of you know how many of you
know what a Harlequin romance is.
Okay,
good.
So those are archetypal stories,
right?
That's the taming of the wild man.
Essentially by the,
by the desirable and virgin a woman.
And if you think women don't want that,
then you better bloody well come up with
an explanation for 50 shades of grey.
Right?
Which is the most,
the most rapid selling novel in human
history and emerged at exactly the same
time that all of this noise about the
lack of the absence of gender roles is
being produced on Mohs.
It's like perfect female fantasy.
It's exactly archetypally correct.
It's beauty and the beast.
So what the deal guys showed was the
structure of beauty and the beast,
although they didn't use that as a
reference that the female pornographic
fantasy was wild guy,
you know,
somewhat careless about the wants and
desires of others attractive to
everyone.
Therefore,
high status,
tamed by the magic of a single woman and
brought into a relationship with her.
Okay.
So,
but here's the comical part.
This just made me laugh,
man.
It was like,
what were the five categories of most
desirable male entity used most broadly
and female pornography?
Oh,
it's so embarrassing.
Women,
you have to cover your head.
Will I say this because Vampire
Werewolf,
billionaire surgeon and pirate.